on the ninth day of Christmas Iran may
give to me
death to Ayatollah Khomeini brutal
clashes in the streets as the Islamic
Republic's thug regime is on the ropes
Mideast analyst Joshi asma joins to
analyze what the riots mean for the
United States and the world order then a
man to press to giacomo and amber Athey
joined the panel of deplorable z-- to
talk Huma Comey and the deep state DOJ
the first abortion clinic free state in
the Union and the widespread shock that
a youtube star known only for smashing
dinner plates on the Internet has turned
out to be somewhat gauche
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Happy New Year everybody well it feels
like it's been forever that we haven't
been on the air another Kingdom my
podcast with Andrew Klavan has also been
on a hiatus I got a bunch of hate mail
about that but it's going back this
Friday and I I did want to share with
you before we get in there's a lot of
news to talk about today but I haven't
seen you since we had our daily wire
Christmas party it was a lovely affair
there were ugly sweaters and everybody
came and Ben gave me my Christmas
present so I was very excited he it came
in a little blue box and you know you
know what that does to a girl when she
sees a little blue box I got very
excited my heart started to flutter and
then he gave me that's right almost a
diamond almost a diamond it is it is a
lump of coal this was my Christmas
present from Ben but you know someday
after enough time that's gonna that's
gonna be a diamond and I'll and I'll
wear it right on my finger it'll be
really nice so thank you for that I hope
everyone had a good Christmas and a good
New Year let's get right into the news
did you know that there are violent
protests throughout Iran maybe now you
do but did you know three days ago when
they started happening because there has
been a media blackout of coverage and
I'm not talking about the Iranian
state-run media that also has a blackout
but on Thursday as the anti-government
protests in Iran were reaching critical
mass throughout the country The
Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness put protests for democracy in
total darkness instead the Washington
Post covered these were their main
headlines on their website quote
late-night writers dish about their
favorite moments in 2017 Democrats think
2018 will be a good year but they are
are they being realistic and Trump's
respite at mar-a-lago creates headaches
for White House staffers they they also
ran a peace making excuses for why
Americans distrust the mainstream media
you absolutely cannot make that up
CNN ran the alternate fact fake news
headline Iranians hold pro-government
rallies not quite right I think you're
sort of missing the forest for the trees
there there are major anti-government
protests now throughout the country
including in the most religious and
conservative cities in Iran why the
media blackout you ask well because
those protests reflect very poorly on
Barack Obama of course
we can't cover that we can't cover
things critical of Barack Obama so about
the Obama's trouble with Iran began in
2009 there was the green movement there
he refused to support the
anti-government protestors he wouldn't
help them at at all it died out a lot of
people were imprisoned and killed for
that his signature foreign policy
achievement was the Iran deal after
which Barack Obama flew 400 million
dollars in cash to the thuggish regime
and 1.3 billion dollars in additional
funding that was opened up to Iran Iran
is the most prolific state sponsor of
terror in the world and yet here is
Barack Obama touting that deal today
because America negotiated from a
position of strength and principle we
have stopped the spread of nuclear
weapons in this region because of this
deal the international community will be
able to verify that the Islamic Republic
of Iran will not develop a nuclear
weapon this deal meets every single one
of the bottom lines that we established
when we achieved a framework earlier
this spring every pathway to a nuclear
weapon is cut off and the inspection and
transparency regime necessary to verify
that objective will be put in place here
is footage of Ayatollah Khomeini
negotiating the deal he has perfect
English
I am shocked at what how an excellent
English the Ayatollah has that is much
more accurate virtually nothing Barack
Obama said was true
we didn't [ __ ] I guess we negotiated
from a position of strength
we just didn't exercise any of that
strength it doesn't cut off the
possibility of Iran getting a nuclear
weapon if anything it hastens it by
giving them a ton more capital obviously
they started cheating on the deal right
away according to a number of foreign
policy experts so it was a total failure
just like every other Barack Obama
negotiating technique we give them
anything we give our adversaries
everything for some reason we sell
flagellate we apologize for things we
never did and then they get
everything and they smack us around for
it and it wasn't only Republicans who
pointed out that this was a terrible
deal here his current Democrat Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer's take a mint quote
I will vote to disapprove the agreement
not because I believe war is a viable or
desirable option not to challenge the
path of dis plumbin C is because I
believe Iran will not change do you know
how many times I agree with Chuck
Schumer ever in history very few this
might be the one exception but obviously
he felt strongly about it and his vote
didn't matter ultimately for the deal
so he voted his conscience and what his
what his donors and his constituents
wanted so what should the United States
position be I as always and with the so
subtle john bolton right so I think we
do need to provide assistance I think we
can do it in several ways number one
this is yet another reason why the
president should get out of the nuclear
deal with Iran should resume all of our
previous sanctions putting increased
economic pressure on the regime we
should provide material financial
support to the opposition if they desire
it we should work with intelligence
services from other countries Saudi
Israel to provide more pressure there's
a lot we can do and we should do it our
goal should be regime change in Iran
john bolton doesn't mince words I think
he's exactly right president Trump by
the way his voiced support for the
Iranian protesters he tweeted out for
major tweets of Memphis he said many
reports of peaceful protests by Iranian
citizens fed up with the regime's
corruption its squandering of the
nation's wealth to fund terrorism
Iranian government should respect their
people's rights including the right to
express themselves the world is watching
later the big protests in Iran people
are finally getting wise as to how their
money and wealth is being stolen and
squandered on terrorism looks like they
will not take it any longer the USA is
watching very closely for human rights
violations
next week Iran the number one state
sponsor of terror with numerous
violations of human rights occurring on
an hourly basis has now closed down the
internet not good
and then finally Iran is failing at
every level despite the terrible deal
made with them probably Obama
administration
the great Iranian people have been
repressed for many years they're hungry
for food and for freedom along with
human rights the wealth of Iran is being
looted time for change how ominous with
that we bring on Iran expert Joshi Asma
who has contributed reporting on these
protests to a number of major outlets
and so I brought on Josh to clear this
up because nobody knows anything about
Iran Josh thank you for being here
thanks for having what's going on what
should we know about this
so these protests began late Thursday
and they began rather small they began
as an anti rouhani protest and so Ron is
the the president rouhani is a car is a
leader president Hassan rouhani this is
a guy who was touted by the Obama
administration as a moderate and he
didn't point out the fact that
executions have skyrocketed under
rouhani attacks acid attacks against
women have skyrocketed this is not a
good guy he's not a moderate the the
whole hardliner moderate dichotomy just
is pure fiction because this is all we
heard from Barack Obama's there's a
moderate in Iran rouhani is a moderate
we should support him to liberalize Iran
that's nonsense you're saying it's
absolute nonsense and the reason why is
every presidential candidate is vetted
by the mullahs there's something called
The Guardian Council and the Guardian
Council of Vettes candidates and we saw
back in 2009 they didn't like a
candidate most savvy and that's that's
why we had the Green Revolution because
the mullahs suppressed this candidate
and they said that we're only going to
put fourth candidates that are vetted
and that subscribe to the Islamist
regime toe the party line to the
Islamist line so how should the United
States respond I think the Trump
administration has been doing a good job
so far it's funny that could just be the
the mantra of my show the sense of the
show began I think the Trump
administration has been doing pretty
good so far to be fair I've been a
pretty avid trump critic so I don't say
that lightly he's been doing a good job
nikki Haley spoke earlier today and she
said that we're going to hold an
emergency session at the United Nations
we're going to support the Iranian
people
and they've been doing a good job at not
inciting and not giving the ayatollahs
an excuse to make it seem like there is
Western interference blame all of this
on the West it's just the West stirring
up trouble yes and the ayatollahs are
gonna do that anyway and they have been
Khamenei he spoke out for the first time
Tuesday and he blamed the the enemies of
the Iranian regime
so what practically I don't think we're
gonna put boots on the ground but I do
have greater faith in nikki Haley and
Donald Trump to back up their threats
with action something that Barack Obama
never did what materially what tangibly
can the United States do to support this
movement so first and foremost we need
to understand that this movement would
not have happened several years ago the
reason why is because now about 50
million Iranians have access to the
Internet and this revolution if you
could call it that is being fueled by an
app called telegram telegram is huge
Iranians use it it's very Farsi friendly
videos are being uploaded and right now
telegram is being blocked by the Iranian
regime the Iranian regime is blocking
internet in most major cities they're
blocking social media twitter has been
blocked since 2009 and what the United
States needs to do they need to put
pressure on companies like telegram they
need to be pressure on social media
outlets to keep the lines of
communication open because that's the
lifeline of the of the protest base that
is like shut down the communication this
thing I mean this is all over the
country and some of the most religious
cities exactly there's a city called
home and them is the Shia heartland of
Iran this is a place where in 1962
Ayatollah Khomeini began his Islamist
revolution and you we had protesters
there Friday Friday after prayer and
this is when people the people get riled
up this is when the Imams come out and
rile up the people and they went out in
the clerical heartland of the city and
said death to the Islamic Republic death
to Khamenei that's like let's get going
ayatollah exact leader of iran exactly
it could be killed for that they could
be killed and right now in tehran 450
arrests
the regime has already said that they
face they face the death penalty
they're gonna kill them or they have to
kill them although they may kill them
all or like they did in 2009 they could
torture them really brutally Wow
so speaking of Ayatollah Khomeini and
it's a little confusing the old guy was
Khomeini and the new guy is Khamenei
coming comment yeah I don't care
I don't do ya know I always noticed this
my lefty friends they always try to
pronounce things very exaggerated Lee
native so they'll say you know like like
Muslim Pakistan but I don't go to
Italian restaurants and say like okay
I'd like to order the spaghetti and I
kind of bone out a bit father would have
been no you just you know so I like to
very ostentatiously pronounce them in an
anglicized way now what their one thing
they're chanting in the streets
according to the reporting that we have
is bring back the Shah the Shah who was
ousted in the Iranian Revolution what
what does that mean it's a way to defy
the regime there is no topic more taboo
in the Islamic Republic of Iran than the
Shah this is this is why we had the 1979
revolution you had Islamist factions you
had the working poor stand up and say we
don't want the autocratic Shah and to be
to be clear the Schad does not have
immense support in Iran and he does not
have the immense support in the iranian
exile community it's just like a screw
you basically it's basically screw you
and it's basically a way to invoke
nostalgia for a time in a place that was
better than now to make iran great again
exactly the shot 2018 thank you Ron
great again so the last thing I want to
talk to you about the Obama fans are
taking credit for this and they're
saying look the deal gave them a ton of
money and it exposed weaknesses in their
economy which then led to another
protest which were we still in power we
wouldn't support it all but because
we're not in power we'll take some
credit for it is this all revisionist
nonsense or is there something to it
it's revisionist nonsense that's what I
thought I'm glad you said there is I
mean check Twitter the probably the most
smug human being on the planet Ben
Rhodes I knew you were gonna say Ben
Rhodes the smuggest he is he is awful he
was smug in office yeah
he was the one who who joked about how
he fooled the American people and they
were all a bunch of rubes yeah
Javad Zarif who was iran's Foreign
Minister he negotiated the Iran nuclear
deal with Kerry he's he was a smartest
man in the room and he fooled he fooled
Americans essentially and what we're
seeing now is we're seeing a backlash by
the Iranian people because Rohani
over-promised
yeah as a result of the nuclear do the
nuclear deal he said that this is going
to open up the world the banking system
sanctions relief and he didn't deliver
and Iran is still impoverished drug drug
abuse is up prostitution is up and these
people are suffering and the Obama
administration did little to alleviate
their misery rouhani has done very
little to help the working poor and bear
in mind that the the regime always
blames these sorts of dissonant
movements on the middle or upper classes
right and because they draw a huge
portion of their support from the
working class and that's because they've
made the working class dependent on the
government's and welfare benefits it's
all handouts for the working all
handouts and they expect blind
allegiance in return and this is very
much a working-class revolution it looks
like they started it now it seems from
the reporting I read the working class
started this as an economic movement and
not only later did the middle classes
jump on about political oppression and
suppression but this began with the with
the working poor in Iran that's exactly
right
it began as an anti rouhani protest that
basically they express their grievances
over the lack of economic growth but
it's become an anti Ayatollah oh it has
as of Friday it became a political
movement so it's not it's no longer it's
no longer just about the regime that
happens to be running the government
this is about the whole governmental
system and structure of Iran they want
to tear it all down Wow gotta love it
it's kind of like in America we do that
sometimes a little less bloody a little
a little more fun you know it's
tear down the establishment but clearly
anti-establishment movements have spread
even to Iran and maybe the United States
will support it okay we're gonna keep
you around for the panel can you stick
around
of course okay we have an excellent
panel you no longer have to look at his
mug you can look over we have a man to
press to Giacomo and amber 82 come on
and lighten the place up a little bit
but before we do that I'm sorry guys if
you're on Facebook and YouTube
you got it over to daily wire.com we
thank everybody who already subscribes
you help keep the lights on you help
keep cafe in my class which is really
enjoyable now on the ninth day of
Christmas when the Iran may give to me
the death of Ayatollah Khomeini you're
gonna see floods of this Barack Obama's
only foreign policy achievement and a
dubious achievement at that is this Iran
nuclear deal and we're now seeing it was
a miserable awful deal rejected not only
by Americans but by the citizens of Iran
as well the the tears are gonna start
flowing you need to get this leftist
ears tumblr if you subscribe to the
daily wire it's $10 a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
under Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show no ads on the website
that's great you need do not drown do
not be caught in the flood in the deluge
and and say that I didn't warn you DLE
wire.com right now we'll be right back
ladies thank you for being here happy
New Year to Amanda and amber Happy New
Year thanks for having us so let's get
right into the news let's get right into
the Trump tweets I was I was kind of
tuned out from Twitter and the news over
Christmas and New Year's but I would
still check his tweets and he had some
golden ones so this one today he tweeted
quote crooked Hillary Clinton's top aide
uma Abidine has been accused of
disregarding basic security protocols
she put classified passwords into the
hands of foreign agents remember sailors
pictures on submarine jail deep State
Justice Department must finally act also
on Comey and others this oh happy New
Year to us Amanda should Hillary and
Huma go to the clink isn't there
something unsavory about sending
political opponents to jail I don't
think Trump actually wants that to
happen I think he's just riling up his
base and making a point that there's
been no real evidence of collusion and
he's in all this trouble they have this
big investigation and you know on the
other side we have emma-crats who were
clearly break like breaking the law
being completely negligent and nothing
happens so I don't I don't think we want
to put Hillary in jail as much as I
would personally love that because it it
would be breaking precedent success very
impressive actually wants to do that
yeah an Amber that's a great point
Amanda I mean this is basically Donald
Trump's first tweet of the new year he
sent out a few others but you know early
morning on the first day back from work
with so much going his way the economy
tax reform foreign affairs why is Donald
Trump setting off this news cycle with
Huma and jail and crooked Hillary's old
campaign pals okay I also didn't hear
what Amanda said so if I repeat anything
she said I apologize I know I was also
just dumbstruck gazing at her beauty but
and this happens to a lot of people we
have to persevere yeah but I mean so
actually I have to take a little bit of
credit here being at the Daily Caller
because the Daily Caller released a
report this morning about Huma
her passwords to Yahoo which was then
hacked by a foreign spy
so Trump obviously saw the report
thought it was worth tweeting out and I
think we're all pretty honored here that
he kicked off the new year with a tweet
about one of our reports that is really
gold and the Daily Caller by the way is
one of my favorite websites with the
word daily in it it is one of them
hopefully about Daily Mail you know
that's certainly the case Josh he talked
about the deep state
but isn't the Justice Department run by
Trump's own appointees why would he call
them the deep State
I think trub should stay off Twitter for
a little while you know there's this
whole bashing Hillary thing it's been a
year get over it start governing ayahs
governing he's doing a great job
governing I'm sorry to cut you I'm not
that sorry to cut you I love the truth I
think the conventional wisdom says get
off Twitter don't tweet you're hurting
your own agenda he's been incredibly
effective in his first year he's been
more effective than any first year
Republican administration that I can
think of in history and he's been
tweeting the whole way distracting the
media setting the news cycles I love it
like give me the Marco FFA the more the
better
any other thoughts on that I hate to cut
you off but I don't really I don't
really mind frankly I just like to hear
nikki Haley talk but that's just me fair
enough that's true I'll watch Trump
tweeting listen to nikki Haley talk okay
there is one little aspect of this which
is he is keeping the fire on Democrats
he's keeping the fire on the double
standard as Amanda said you're gonna
hear more about Bob Muller or they're
gonna find somebody to indict you could
indict a ham sandwich and so he's
keeping the fire on them pointing out
their corruption ironically their own
collusion and I'm a big fan of this and
let's not forget they're 100 and some
odd thousand employees of the Justice
Department and so the question of the
deep state is not some crazy conspiracy
it's a point that Antonin Scalia himself
raised many times which is that the
great threat to freedom in the United
States or these unaccountable executive
agencies that have gotten too much power
and not enough accountability and if
Donald Trump is going to rein them in in
kind of quirky and uncouth ways that's
fine by me the point is we have to rein
them in and and I'm fine with it and
I'll enjoy the co5 a well it happened
okay
another excellent news story Kentucky is
poised to be the first state in the
country to be abortion clinic free
Amanda you covered this for The Daily
wire and if you haven't checked it out I
don't want to ruin it go over and read
Amanda's piece because her writing is so
good and she uses very funny word choice
Amanda thank you
is this a trend that we're gonna see
spread to other states there are seven
states right now that have one abortion
clinic left and I think the pro-life
movement has been doing a really good
job of basically getting these these
places closed down it and of course
voters and winning over Congress and
getting Republicans in office has really
helped us and now that we have president
Trump as well you know eventually
defunding Planned Parenthood yes this
trend is going to continue and these are
basic safety standards that the pro-life
movement is pouncing on as they should I
mean there have been women who have been
killed because of Borch botched
abortions so that's just a basic
regulation like you have to have context
with an ambulance so they can come if
God forbid something happens if you
can't comply you can't get a license and
that's what's happening in Kentucky so
the pro-life movement is being really
smart and they're caring about women's
safety and as a result they're stopping
the deaths of a lot of babies and saving
a lot of mothers and it's been this
tremendous growth over time as as you
point out the pro-life movement has
gained a lot of steam now we're having
major victories like ridding whole
states of these abortion clinics which
are awful the media would always black
out all the awful stories about abortion
clinics killing women injuring women
right obviously
improperly disposing of babies bodies
the Gosnell stories that is probably the
biggest example of this total media
blackout
now amber yeah what does the success of
the pro-life movement tell us about
other seemingly hopeless social
movements we were told for years
abortion is a done deal it was decided
by the supreme
or move on there are other fish to fry
but is that the case what what about
other movements say redefining marriage
say other aspects of culture that the
pronoun issue the bathroom issue are
these lost causes or should the cultural
right fight back I wouldn't say that
they're necessarily lost causes in the
case of gay marriage that one might mean
so just because abortion is a little bit
of a trickier issue because there are
ways to restrict it without violating
the Supreme Court's decision I'm not
sure that a similar analogy exists for
gay marriage but I think it's definitely
is a testament to just how effective
these grassroots movements from pro-life
people really are and just how effective
they've been in pushing back against
especially the feminist narratives that
what they call reproductive justice
which just means abortion is somehow a
women's rights issue and they've really
been able to reframe that narrative to
everyone has a right to life and that
includes unborn children so I think you
know it's something a testament to the
strength of the grassroots movements if
that extends to other social movements
it kind of depends on the particular
intricacies of those debates as well
absolutely right and in news that is
much less important than saving babies
and women throughout the United States
and re-establishing the world order and
taking away terrorist regimes we have to
talk about a youtube store in utterly
shocking news the YouTube star Logan
Paul posted a video walking through a
Japanese forest in which he stumbled
upon a post suicide corpse some guy who
had killed himself in Japan here's a
censored clip of the video one of my
classmate in the junior high school he
really killed himself oh yeah what he
was kidding only 21 no Logan
excuse me now the Internet is seriously
piling on this guy
he pulled the video pretty quickly he
apologized immediately he even seemed
pretty shaken in the video he made
several serious statements in it about
how suicide isn't a joke there's help
reach out if you need help that sort of
thing he is one of the biggest stars on
YouTube and there are now widespread
calls to D monetize his channel
something we all know a lot about on the
conservative side of YouTube we know a
lot about D monetizing they people want
to kick him off of YouTube to put this
in his channel has almost three billion
views and here is one present
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that was gonna shatter I
mean I don't know plastic shatters like
glass sorry
hi art in 2017 2018 Amanda is it it
really shocking that a guy who's only
demonstrable talent is smashing dinner
plates in his apartment then he might be
somewhat gauche
why is everybody piling on this guy yeah
I didn't I didn't know who he was I
still kind of don't and and I won't
watch that clip because I just can't do
it but yeah I don't I don't know I think
that Ben Shapiro wrote a piece about
this today and it's it's kind of like
this outrage culture like the Ponzi
scheme where you know if you're more
outraged you have more virtue so it is
disgusting and I totally good with that
but people feel good calling other
people out because you know they're
better than that so there's a lot of
there's a lot of virtue signaling going
on then even though it's probably
expected for this person it doesn't
matter you're gonna you're gonna look
like a good person for calling this this
out even though you know everyone knows
yeah that was a bad move and then he
pulled it because it was a bad move he
knew it was a bad move he apologized
profusely I think genuinely even in the
video he appeared pretty genuinely
shaken by it and was making serious
statements I think Ben's piece on it if
you haven't read it it's at the Daily
wire it was really good it was really
spot-on it's so easy it's so cost free
to say oh look at that awful terrible
person yes I agree aren't we both
wonderful together but it's all these
Twitter hashtag movements like you have
to really do anything you just you just
put out a statement
throw in a hashtag and you're a good
person right so it's it doesn't make any
sense that's slacktivism it's that
hashtag yeah some of yes I take mental
health and suicide very seriously see I
tweeted about it I tweeted I'm gonna
love me love me now Josh does an apology
ever suffice anymore you know he made a
mistake he apologized in the age of
insta Fame why are people so quick to
judge to be honest I don't understand
why people aren't talking about the
cultural condition in Japan why are we
talking about this slightly for just do
if you have an aging population in Japan
you have you know their economy has gone
slightly down you have they can't
replace their workforce young Japanese
men have a lot of weirdness about sex
they're not having sex they're all
addicted to porn are they're all
addicted to porn let's talk about
Japan let's talk about the young men
killing themselves why are we talking
about this buffoon I don't I don't
understand that's a phenomenal point
because I'm looking at this from a
bizarrely cultural perspective why we
have this outraged culture
whyever everyone else is looking at it
from the other side of that cultural
paradigm which is we need to kill this
guy and he's really famous for doing
nothing and shrieking like an animal on
the internet but now we have to smack
him around because apparently he's not
very polite the thing that he's talking
about the video that he's actually
making shows a bizarre phenomenon in
Japan but no one wants to talk about
that that's too hard and serious and not
clicky enough there that you don't smash
a lot of plates when you're talking
about suicide do you it's not as
interesting amber is the fame of people
like this guy or other totally
nonsensical YouTube stars represent a
shift in culture it's so easy
conservatives are always talking about
the decay and culture and everything's
awful now and you know rock and roll is
gonna make all the kids immoral or is
this guy just a clown like we've had in
every single era well if I understand
correctly I think the vast majority of
his fan base is like young kids and
middle schoolers who are really
attracted to that yeah they're I mean
obviously they're gonna be attracted to
this kind of like a slapstick kind of
humor I guess if you could even call it
humor but I think this also speaks to a
larger point about what technology has
is doing to our lives in the sense that
every part of this person's life is
considered content for his YouTube
channel there's nothing about him that's
private and so for him going into the
woods and seeing a person who had just
committed suicide was just another piece
of viral content it was a way for him to
get views and that's what happens when
people live their lives behind a camera
or behind a phone is that everything is
just another way for people to click on
you and think that you're interesting
and it never runs out there's you always
need a higher high you always need more
outrageous content if your whole shtick
is not to analyze anything or to produce
any art or do anything within confines
if it's just a shock then eventually
you're going to end up
the guy hanging from a tree in Japan
because that's right analysts this was
like the holy grail of content for him I
mean if it was allowed to stay up on
YouTube I can only imagine how many
views he would have gotten out of it
then that is the question how do I get
more clicks how do I get more views and
yet you see people when they fly a
little too close to the Sun when people
are only provocateurs and they're not
offering any value I don't want to call
out people on the right but of certain
of these provocateurs their names might
run with bi-lo you Napoles when they all
they do is an outrage and they don't
offer any substance then eventually
you're going to go a little too far and
you're gonna fizzle out I wonder if
maybe that insta Fame coaches is finally
recognizing that with one of the biggest
stars on YouTube now going down in
flames if maybe there will be a shift
even on that platform but who knows that
they're gonna demonetised and censor all
of us before before any of that happens
so we won't be around to see it okay
ladies thank you for being here happy
new year so good to see what a great way
to start off 2018 Josh a much less
enjoyable way to start off 2018 but
nevertheless thank you for the analysis
good to see you that's our show today I
am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow
tune into another Kingdom on Friday and
we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017